bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission où on applique les gestes
barrière jusqu'à l'extrême le
présentateur n'est pas là
et bienvenue à vous à danser casse pour
notre émission dédiée à l'actualité
économique de la semaine olivier bonjour
bonjour mira est avec nous aujourd'hui
olivier à dany langue il est économiste
et maître de conférences en économie à
l'université paris xiii dany langue
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
bonjour et moi contrairement à olivier
je suis là voilà bien présent alors
quels sont les sujets qui ont fait
l'actualité économique des derniers
jours tout d'abord la dette américaine
on peut même parler de l'explosion de la
dette américaine le chiffre est
impressionnant
trente mille milliards de dollars c'est
l'équivalent de 125 % de son pib et la
vitesse à laquelle cette dette s'est
creusée est impressionnante plus de 7000
milliards de dollars depuis 2019 et puis
regardez un vous allez voir tout de
suite les états unis un capitaine de la
dette puisque l'ensemble des pays de
l'union européenne c'est treize mille
500 milliards de dollars de dette la
chine 12 1600 milliards de dollars
olivier pourquoi autant de dettes pour
les états unis est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'il ait eu beaucoup de dépenses liées
au co vide
non monsieur simplement c'est simplement
le cours normal des choses je dirais
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui on ne
fonctionne plus que par la dette donc ya
pas de croissance donc on la remplace
par la mer l'activité remplacée par de
la neige vous avez la même chose en
france vous avez la même chose où l'avez
vu dans d'autres pays la français est
quasiment sûre au même niveau sauf que
on est à 10% en fait deux
de la dette américaine ont des nous
autour de 3000 milliards vous pour un
pib qui est autour de 2400 et bien c'est
c'est à peu près la même chose aux états
unis sauf qu'il ya un zéro de plus mais
c'est tout mais vous allez continuer
comme ça faut pas en douter tout
simplement parce que je vous dis il ya
plus de croissance naturelle il ya plus
de vraie croissance est donc bien on a
remplacé tout simplement
l'activité par de la nette de la dette
qui soit que ce soit de la des publics
ou même que ce soit de la dette privée
qu est ce qu on a fait quand on a mis en
place les pge et bien les pge c'était de
la dette qui
remplaçait de l'activité puisque on
avait arrêté l'activité notamment par
exemple des restaurants ou des des boîte
d'événementiel et c'est donc on a arrêté
leur activité on a remplacé leur chiffre
d'affaires par départ de la dette qui
était garantie par l'état et donc on a
fait ce qu'on a fait à tous les niveaux
dans l'économie aujourd'hui puisque on a
l'impression que en mettant de la dette
eh bien on va obtenir un effet de levier
on va obtenir plus de pim c'est de la
dette qui est là pour payer les dépenses
courantes qui est là pour remplacer
l'activité et ça n'est évidemment pas
normal ça n'est évidemment pas sain et à
un moment on va vous apporter la note il
n'y a pas de free lunch ça n'existe pas
quand vous allez au restaurant et que
vous bas frais pendant des heures et
bien à la fin du déjeuner ou du dîner on
vous apporte la note là c'est ça sera
exactement la même chose dany langues
olivier vient de le dire ce n'est pas
sans ça veut dire qu'il faut s'inquiéter
pour les finances américaines alors là
j'ai un désaccord avec
olivier delamarche je suis
personnellement d'accord des skis dit
notamment sur le fait qu'on
artificiellement alimenter la croissance
parallèle par la dette c'est notamment
la dette privée on n'aurait pas dû faire
les prêts garantis par l'état moi je
pense qu'on aurait dû directement aider
les entreprises au vu de la situation
exceptionnelle plutôt que de faire
encore gonfler la dette privée qui je le
rappelle est toujours la première cause
de crise on l'a vu en 2008 avec le
subprime mais on l'a vu aussi par le
passé la dette privée qui est déjà trop
élevée sur la dette publique j'aurai des
nuances on se retrouve dans une
situation économique extrêmement
compliqué à la suite de la crise de 2008
est en partie parce que les états
européens n'ont pas assez relancer leurs
activités les etats unis ont pris la
mesure de la crise en faisant des plans
de relance massifs et c'est toujours
quand on est en bas du cycle c'est à
dire dans des situations comme la
situation actuelle que ce qu'on appelle
le multiplicateur de dépenses publiques
est le plus élevé c'est prouvé
empiriquement il ya encore des études
récentes par exemple la réserve fédérale
de saint louis qui montre que quand
c'est en bas du cycle quand ça va mal
que la dépense publique est la plus
efficace en matière de pib que ce soit
d'ailleurs de la dépense
d'investissement au delà des pans de
fonctionnement alors évidemment il
aurait mieux fallu il dédié sa de
l'investissement mais c'est ce que fait
en partie joe biden depuis qu'il est
arrivé au pouvoir aux états unis donc et
puis la dette publique on crie souvent
au loup moi je ne suis pas d'accord pour
crier au loup sur la dette publique tout
simplement parce que quand la dette
publique arrive à échéance l'étape
toujours et emprunter la question étant
de savoir à quel taux sur la dette
privée ça m'inquiète beaucoup plus parce
que quand il ya trop de dettes privées
il ya des ménages et des entreprises qui
ne peuvent plus faire face à leurs
échéances et là on a un vrai problème
parce qu'on a des non remboursements et
il est non remboursement men
systématiquement aux crises financières
donc je ne suis que partiellement
d'accord avec eux ce que vous dites
olivier sur la dette publique ça me
paraît pas être le moment de tirer
le signal d'alarmé même si les taux
remontent par contre sur la dette privée
il y a un gros problème et on se trouve
face à une tempête financière devant
laquelle les états risquent de n'avoir
pas beaucoup de levier alors on va avoir
injustement qui détient la dette des
états unis des investisseurs privés à un
bien évidemment mais également des pays
pour près d'un tiers regardez on a le
japon en tête non à la chine un juste
après vient ensuite la grande bretagne
le luxembourg et l'irlande olivier est
ce que c'est un classement qui vous
étonne
non je parais classement qui me qui
m'étonne on leur reconnaît ce classement
dit les îles et il est régulièrement
vous avez de deux 2 pays qui ce qui ce
qui se tirent la bourre pour
pour passer premier
qui a rien d'étonnant là dedans
maintenant vous avez aussi la banque
centrale américaine qui commence à en
détenir un bon paquet de la dette donc
que
le le problème n'est pas là aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que là où je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec dani c'est le sait au
second se fiche de la dette on se fiche
des publics non s'en fiche pas et
surtout pas à ces niveaux là et on sait
très bien que ça va complètement obérer
la croissance ça fait ça fait des années
on l'a bien vu d'ailleurs avec le avec
le japon ça fait des années qu'ils
tournent en rond qui n'arrivent pas à
relancer leur croissance qu'ils ont une
croissance qui est minable et qui est
complètement bouffé par la bête donc on
peut pas dire on s'en fout la dette
c'est de l'impôt futur donc cessé à un
moment on vous apportera la nôtre quoi
qu'il arrive et donc plus elle sera
salée plus ça sera compliqué donc je
suis absolument pas d'accord là dessus
leur set sexuelle à un objet
préoccupations surtout quand ça n'est
pas pour faire des investissements
c'est à dire quelque chose qui vous
rapportera un jour là c'est juste pour
payer la bouffe compte c'est juste pour
payer les le la vie courante mais
imaginez imaginer un ménage qui tous les
tous les mois va la société générale ou
à sa banque pour demander un emprunt à
dix ans pour manger mais c'est pas
possible il ya un moment où ça claque et
donc le le problème c'est que et c'est
justement pour ça que c'est inquiétant
c'est qu'on est rentré dans un système
où on ne peut pas revenir en arrière
c'est à dire que la banque centrale sera
obligé on va en parler un petit peu
après la banque centrale sera obligé de
continuer à faire tourner la planche à
billets parce qu'elle ne peut plus faire
autrement il faut bien quelqu'un à
chaque cette dette des pays qui vont les
mettre et donc à partir de ce moment là
vous allez faire dégringoler la monnaie
alors ça sera une autre moi ça sera un
autre moyen de payer c'est d'accord mais
c'est pas plus réjouissant que
autre chose alors on est pressé par le
temps va tout de suite passé au sujet
suivant
et on va parler de christine lagarde à
la tête de la bce la banque centrale
européenne 1 toutes les banques
centrales et c'est un de juguler
l'inflation pendant que christine
lagarde est plutôt optimiste c'est le
tiroir cash d'antoine basse
[Musique]
ces dernières semaines sur mettez tous
les présidents de banques centrales dans
un bateau il y aurait ceux qui sautent à
l'eau et puis il y aurait christine
lagarde qui reste coûte que coûte sur
l'embarcation ah oui je sais pas nager
bon la métaphore est un peu simpliste
mais visualiser que l'eau en fait c'est
l'inflation qui monte doucement mais
sûrement pour la freiner la plupart des
chefs des banques centrales du monde ont
déjà annoncé vouloir arrêter de noyer
les banques et des états de liquidités
et remonter leurs taux directeurs c'est
le cas en angleterre qui vient de
l'augmenter à 0,5 pour cent au brésil
aussi ça pourrait arriver très vite en
norvège mais pas la bce pas christine
lagarde non même si elle commence à
avoir les pieds dans l'eau en août les
escarpins elle a annoncé garder le même
cap monétaire à contre courant de ses
homologues meiway salé ou l'a compris et
c'est suffisamment rare pour être
soulignée de jérôme poële le président
de la réserve fédérale américaine qui
lui a annoncé une première hausse des
taux dès le mois de mars se gardera
d'avancé quelle stratégie fonctionnera
au final qui saura le mieux surfer sur
la vague du succès et qui réussira à
casser cette translation tu pars de
l'irlande jusqu'à la grèce sans toucher
la suisse et u15 du corse mais on craint
que tout director relever ou pas tout le
monde finisse par boire la tasse
cité christine lagarde indirectement je
ne prends jamais d'engagement sans les
assortir de conditions il est encore
plus important en ce moment d'être
attentif nous évaluerons la situation
très attentivement en fonction des
données nous effectuerons ce travail en
mars des milans pourquoi christine
lagarde attend et qu'est ce qu'elle
attend alors je dis souvent que
j'aimerais peut être un banquier central
en ce moment pour une raison simple
c'est que vous ne disposez pas en tant
que banque centrale des instruments qui
sont nécessaires à juguler l'inflation
qu'on a aujourd'hui cette inflation est
liée en grande partie aux rattrapages
noé nomi on a produit en quelques mois
ce qu'on aurait dû produire en deux ans
à cause du que vide et donc on se
retrouve dans les chaînes global de
valeur avec certains secteurs comme le
secteur des semi conducteurs qui sont
complètement saturé et d'autres secteurs
qui n'arrive pas à se procurer les
matières premières dont et dont ils ont
besoin par exemple le secteur automobile
pour produire donc la vraie question
c'est de savoir si cette inflation
conjoncture est donc lié à la reprise on
produit en quelques mois ce qu'on aurait
dû produit en plusieurs d'années ou si
elle est structurelle est donc lié aux
politiques monétaires il ya très peu de
cette inflation qu'il est aux politiques
monétaires le seul aspect à mon avis qui
est vraiment lié à ces politiques
monétaires c'est qu'on a inondé le
marché de prêts à très bas taux et donc
ça a provoqué un peu partout des bulles
immobilières donc les banques centrales
savais qu'à un moment elle devrait
remonter les taux d'intérêt le problème
de cet outil de la remontée des taux
d'intérêt c'est que vous êtes sûr de
ralentir l'économie mais vous n'êtes pas
sûr de juguler cette inflation qui est
quand même très largement dû à des
facteurs autres que les politiques
monétaires des banques centrales et
c'est très très difficile en ce moment
d'être en banquier central parce que
vous ne disposez pas des outils pour
juguler l'inflation quelques années
c'est pas une inflation d'origine
salariale comme dans les années 60 ou 70
c'est une inflation qui est clairement
lié à un engorgement des chaînes global
de valeur donc c'est très très embêtant
de se retrouver dans cette situation
c'est pas une inflation qui vit au plein
emploi on en est très très loin dans
notre pays donc il dans d'autres pays
donc vraiment c'est embêtant et je pense
à mon avis qu'eux
monter un peu l'étau ou les laisser
inchangés il n'ya pas une différence
énorme entre ce que fait christine
lagarde est ce que font les autres et je
ne pense pas que les banques centrales
et les outils pour juguler cette
inflation et on va s'arrêter quelques
instants c'est l'heure de marquer une
courte pause à tout de suite
est de retour dans ces cas ce toujours
avec nous dany longue vous êtes
économiste et maître de conférences en
économie à l'université
paris xiii et puis olivier et bien sûr
on va continuer avec vous viviez de
parler de christine lagarde 1 christine
lagarde à la tête de la bce qui
manifestement est à contre courant des
autres directeurs de banques centrales
pour moi le aujourd'hui là il ya deux
source d'inflation il ya la
désorganisation des circuits de
production avec le plus grand port
chinois qui qui est bloqué parce qu'il
ya trois personnes qui ont un rhume
avec donc le tout ces politiques de 2,0
stock de flux tendu qui fait qu'
évidemment avec ses désorganisation et
bien il ya des goulots d'étranglement
qui font que il ya de l'inflation mais
il n'y a pas d'activité il suffit
d'ailleurs de regarder les les
utilisations de capacités qui sont
encore très très très très basse donc
c'est pas un problème qui vient de là
vous avez vous avez une activité qui est
relativement faible
même si halluin un rebond parce qu'après
un arrêt il suffit pas grand chose pour
que ça rebondisse
mais c'est pas l'activité qui qui est en
train de tirer ses je vous dis dans une
désorganisation du haut que vides ou en
tout cas la question du coc vide et de
voeux le ski mis sur les marchés et ce
qui est mis sur les marchés oui vas dans
l'immobilier mais il va aussi dans les
actions il va aussi dans les obligations
et figurez vous qu'il va aussi dans les
matières premières puisque les matières
premières elles sont cotées et donc on
va on va jouer dessus vous avez
l'exemple que je donne fréquemment qui
est le sucre 1 vous avez pas tous
bouffés plus de sucre là depuis depuis
quelques semaines bon sauf que le sucre
il est passé de 10 à 20 à 10 à 20 ça
fait quand même le doubs et c'est pas du
tout à une suractivité ou à une
surconsommation sucre cedus simplement
au fait qu' on s'est dit ah bah tiens ce
truc là il n'a pas bougé donc on va les
jouer dessus et est pour beaucoup de
matières premières malheureusement c'est
ça et donc on a un vrai problème
là-dessus et c'est pour ça que pour moi
les banquiers centraux aujourd'hui ont
le cul entre deux chaises et le savent
ils le savent très bien c'est à dire qu'
il faut que les les obligations arrivent
à échéance il faut qu'elle soit rouler
et dans de bonnes conditions à 3% c'est
pas la même que casero et donc
et que les états doivent encore émettre
énormément de
avec les déficits budgétaires qu'ils ont
ils vont être obligés d'émettre encore
beaucoup d'obligations et que la banque
centrale le sait est qu'aujourd'hui elle
allait les fesses entre deux chaises
pourquoi pas parce qu'il ya d'un côté
l'inflation dont elle sait qu'elle est
en grande partie responsable
et puis de l'autre côté vous avez le leu
leu l'activité dont elle sur lequel elle
a finalement pas la main et puis
et puis donc c'est du discours c'est de
la com c'est à dire exactement comme
vous aviez eu fin 2018 souvenez-vous
powell était venu nous expliquer que
l'activité était reparti que tout allait
bien aux états unis et que donc on
pouvait remonter les taux et même il
avait donné un target qui était de trois
et demi en disant que l'économie
américaine pouvait soutenir ces trois et
demi pour cent sauf que deux semaines
plus tard ou trois semaines plus tard
quand les marchés avaient bien secoué et
qu'ils étaient à moins 20 sur d'autres
d'autres eh bien monsieur powell est
revenu en disant bah oui excusez moi on
s'est mal compris j'avais mal analysé la
situation et je baisse les taux et je
recommence mais quantitative easing
c'est exactement ce qui va se passer
parce qu'aujourd'hui ils n'ont plus le
choix ils savent très bien qu'ils sont
dépendants des marchés qui ne sont plus
dépendants des chiffres des chiffres
macroéconomiques à ce dont ils se
foutent d'ailleurs complètement ils
savent depuis longtemps et donc
aujourd'hui c'est le marché qui les
intéressent attendez que le marché est
un peu secouer parce que il a peur des
taux qui remonte il a peur qu'on lui
file plus large en poule et tous les
mois pour qu'il puisse aller faire des
plus values sur le sur le sur les
marchés et donc à ce moment là le marché
va secouer un tout petit peu et vous
verrez les banquiers centraux revenir
ventre à terre en disant ah ah non on
est désolé
mauvaise blague on reverse les taux donc
vous verrez que que ce soit madame
lagarde ou que ce monsieur que ce soit
monsieur powell alors ils ont une
communication pied différentes ok ça va
durer quelques semaines et dans quelques
semaines vous verrez qu'ils baisseront
et cette bonne nouvelle a ou pas en
bolivie
et daniel lang nous le dirons regarder
en 2021 le secteur salarié privé a
dépassé de 3 cents mille emplois elle
son niveau d'avant crise dany langues on
peut le dire il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'intérimaires oui en particulier au
quatrième trimestre la quasi totalité je
me souviens pas très bien de pourcentage
mais il me semble c'est 70% à vérifier
sur le site de l'insee correspond
finalement de l'emploi intérimaire donc
une fois de plus ça renvoie ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est une reprise
en trompe l'oeil parce que on produit en
quelques mois ce qu'on a ce qu'on aurait
dû produire en deux ans et donc les
entreprises ont recours à l'intérim pour
faire face cette augmentation temporaire
de demande dans les secteurs où il ya
une hausse des taux d'utilisation ce qui
n'est pas le cas tous les secteurs donc
donc moi ça me paraît pas extrêmement
surprenants
à mon avis ce sera pas durable olivier
doit-on vraiment continuer à mesure et
l'emploi en terme uniquement quantitatif
non bien sûr que non mais ces problèmes
depuis longtemps le chiffre le chiffre
des deux de l'emploi le chiffre du du
chômage sont des chiffres marketing
politique donc ça n'a aucun intérêt il
vous présente ce qu'ils veulent en vous
disant en criant victoire donc ça vient
appuyer le discours de monsieur le maire
qui se croient reparti pour les trente
glorieuses ont ils vous expliquent qu'il
ya un million d'entreprises créées puis
on s'aperçoit que c'est d'hubert des
livreurs donc question entreprise il ya
qu'avant mais il ya quand même plus
pérenne et plus intéressant et puis on
vous dit ça y est il ya de l'embauché
puis quand vous regardez le le lez lille
i chiffres en effet vous apercevez que
c'est c'est de l'intérim cdu c'est du
cbb s'est
cdd et des contrats précaires etc donc
ça n'a absolument aucun intérêt c'est un
chiffre qui vous permet de rouler des
mécaniques à deux mois deux à deux mois
des élections danny manquait lé place
dans le positif dans cette façon de
présenter les c
effet avec la vague de néolibéralisme à
laquelle on a eu droit depuis les années
80 partout on a vu l'apparition de ce
que davie grabherr abel les multis gucci
diop cdc des jobs mal payés mal
rémunérés pas forcément utile
socialement donc la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir comment on
peut créer des emplois de qualité et qui
seront socialement utiles les emplois
socialement utiles comme par exemple les
gens qui nettoie les hôpitaux qui évite
les maladies nosocomiales sont
extrêmement mal rémunérés et quand on
regarde comment l'emploi est
comptabilisé est bon pour être chômeurs
de catégorie à c'est-à-dire pour être
affiché dans les journaux télécom comme
chômeur il faut absolument pas avoir
travaillé lors du mois précédent sinon
passer en catégorie b ou en catégorie c
si vous avez travaillé plus de 76 et en
en moi donc déjà il ya nombre d'heures
vous avez travaillé mais si vous
continuez quand même à chercher un
emploi c'est que vous quand même que
vous n'êtes pas bien dans l'emploi que
vous créez et puis il ya une question de
qualité de l'emploi et d'utilité sociale
de ces emplois moi ça fait longtemps que
je soutiens l'idée qui a été porté
d'ailleurs dans la primaire aux états
unis un emploi garanti
c'est à dire l'idée qu' il faut créer
des emplois temporaires dans des
secteurs qui sont socialement utiles
et que ni l'état ni le marché une arrive
à satisfaire si vous regardez autour de
vous il ya plein de besoin et aucun
d'entre eux n'est satisfait le marché
répond à certains besoins ceux qui sont
profitables l'état répond à certains
besoins ceux qui ont été décidées par
les collectivités locales ou par l'état
mais il ya plein de besoins qui sont
satisfaits ni par l'un ni par l'autre il
y aurait peut-être moyen de créer
beaucoup d'emplois dans ces secteurs est
d'assurer le plein emploi ce qui
permettrait d'assurer une plus grande
stabilité macroéconomique et d'assurer
une croissance de meilleure qualité
alors on allait les apprentis qui ont
largement bénéficié de cette dynamique
698 de contrats d'apprentissage ont été
signés en 2021 c'est 36 % de plus que
l'année précédente et quasiment le
double de 19 olivier
ont écouté of ages je dirais je
on en a parlé des dizaines de fois du
chômage vous ai dit commencer comment
c'était calculé ce qu'on pouvait faire
pour sortir des gens des chiffres du
chômage vous avez vu qu'il y avait deux
selon madame béni qu il y avait 18 % de
radiation des listes des chômeurs enfin
je veux dire il ya trente-six mille
façons vous les mettez en stage vous les
mettez en
formation etc et vous avez vous avez une
diminution des chiffres donc je vous
dise etc c'est devenu réellement un
chiffre marketing qui n'a absolument
aucun intérêt il faut aller regarder
réellement les
classements par classement ce qui se
passe dans le dans l'économie et on
s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui on est bien
bien loin des chiffres qu'on vous d'eux
qu'on vous donne qui est le chiffre 2 je
suis combien 8,8 et demi
qui est grotesque par rapport à ce qui
se passe dans la réalité si vous voulez
les les deux millions personnes qui sont
entrées dans la pauvreté qui sont au rsa
ne sont pas dans les chômeurs donc
pourquoi tout simplement parce que s'ils
sont pas calculés dedans donc pouvait
alors après tout les jouer sur un tiers
joe cole kaige t'en colle
2% plus dans le dans l'apprentissage oui
d'accord mais qu'est ce qui se passe
après vous voulez vous avez des gens qui
sont en formation qui revendra et puis
qui sont pas plus fort mais finalement
que que quand ils sont partis donc et
qui trouveront pas de boulot derrière
enfin je veux dire on
marche sur la tête avec avec les les
chiffres du chômage donc pas ce que
parce qu'on n'a pas ou on ne met pas en
place les choses pour que
réellement il y ait une adéquation déjà
entre les offres et les demandes de
l'équation de formation d'éducation etc
tout ça c'est assez rare en prendre
depuis le début c'est pas juste avec des
petites des petites mesures de
perlimpinpin que ça va fonctionner donc
donc aujourd'hui c'est du joug 10 et du
marketing comme comme bruno qui qui nous
annoncent les trente glorieuses qui nous
annonce
ddd pib qui sont au dessus du pib 2019
parce qu'il sait pas faire un calcul de
pourcentage enfin bon tout ça c'est ça
fait partie du même ça fait partie du
même du même dialogue ça n'a aucun
intérêt mais vraiment qu'un voilà donc
on continue à sa discuter de chiffres
qui sont faux
et qui ne font plaisir que au ministre
qui peut se glorifier n'avoir pas rien
fichu pendant cinq ans dany langues
merci à vous je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et maître de conférences en
économie à l'université paris xiii
berthier vous je vous en prie et olivier
merci à vous également c'est la fin de
cette émission que vous pouvez retrouver
sur notre site internet rt france à
point tv olivier c'est à vous
merci dany écoute si le si la dette
n'est pas importante eh bien nous irons
tous les deux déjeuner au restaurant et
on partira sans payer on verra je ne
m'appelle pas françois fillon
[Rires]
[Musique]